buenas noches raúl desde bogotá detrás
de mí está el monumento a los héroes que
a pesar de la lluvia ha concentrado
centenares de manifestantes es como bien
decíamos hoy se cumple un mes de paro
nacional y sirve también para ver cómo
está la temperatura de estas protestas
que se han visto en ciudades de todo el
país y parece que continúa siendo
caldeado el ambiente especialmente en
cali donde se han vivido distintos
incidentes que han involucrado a civiles
armados disparando contra manifestantes
especialmente grave ha sido el del
sector de la luna donde ha estado
involucrado un personal de la fiscalía
con manifestantes esto es lo que ha
dicho la fiscalía sobre ese suceso
fiscalía general de la nación lamenta y
se solidariza con los familiares de las
víctimas del hecho ocurrido el día de
hoy en el sector de la luna en la ciudad
de cali freddy bermúdez ortiz hoy muerto
en estos mismos hechos era un
funcionario adscrito al cuerpo técnico
de investigación que de acuerdo con la
información recopilada hasta este
momento disparó hacia varias personas
ocasionando la muerte de unos civiles
debe indicarse que este funcionario
ingresó en el año 2012 a la institución
y que en el momento de los hechos no se
encontraba en cumplimiento de alguna
labor propia de su función porque estaba
de descanso
ante esta situación en cali la
gobernadora del valle del cauca ha
pedido a iván duque el despliegue máximo
de fuerza pública algo que se ha ido
sucediendo en todas las semanas y que
después de un mes de protestas todavía
no se ve el resultado sino que se ven
preguntas cómo van esas negociaciones
entre el gobierno y el comité nacional
de paro cómo van a reaccionar los
manifestantes a que el ministro de
defensa diego molano haya superado la
moción de censura son muchas preguntas
donde hay decenas de muertos centenares
de desaparecidos centenares de heridos y
todas estas situaciones hacen que nos
preguntemos si el presidente iván duque
a partir de ahora va a continuar con esa
negociación blanda o si finalmente va a
optar por una negociación dura que pueda
desencallar esta grave situación en
colombia lamentable lluís lo que está
ocurriendo ahora en colombia muchísimas
gracias muy buena noche